The Mother of Dragons has opened up about
some of her biggest behind-the-scenes battles.
In the months after the extraordinarily divisive
ending of Game of Thrones, which closed out
its epic eight-season run in May 2019, Emilia
Clarke, who played Daenerys Targaryen on the
series, has spoken out about tough moments
she experienced during filming, namely the
scenes in which she appeared in the buff,
and there were quite a few.
Speaking with actor Dax Shepard on his podcast
Armchair Expert, Clarke got candid about the
pressure to perform while baring it all and
the toll it took on her, especially considering
the fact that she was quite young when she
began her tenure on Thrones.
Clarke told Shepard that she suffered from
serious imposter syndrome while filming, saying,
"I'd been on a film set twice before then,
and now I'm on a film set completely naked,
with all of these people and I don't know
what I'm meant to do, and I don't know what's
expected of me, and I don't know what you
want, and I don't know what I want."
She told Shepard that both her clothed and
unclothed scenes on Game of Thrones caused
her feelings of anxiety and self-doubt.
Luckily, Clarke had an ally in Aquaman himself,
Jason Momoa, who played her husband Khal Drogo
during the show's first season.
Momoa completely had her back during these
difficult sequences.
"He was an experienced actor who had done
a bunch of stuff before coming on to this,
he was like, 'Sweetie, this is how it's meant
to be and this is how it's not meant to be,
and I'm going to make sure that's the way
it f---ing goes.'"
Clearly, Momoa was warmly protective of Clarke,
who appreciated it immensely.
"He was so kind.."
"He's a prince."
"That's great."
"Yeah.
And considerate and cared about me as a human
being."
However, as more time went by, Clarke realized
she had the clout to stick up for herself
on set, saying that she became "a lot more
savvy" about what she's comfortable doing.
"Like, I've had fights on set before where
I'm like, 'No, the sheet stays up.'
And they're like, 'You don't want to disappoint
your Game of Thrones fans,' and I'm like,
'F--- you.'"
By the time she had to perform her final nude
scene, which took place on the season 6 episode
"Book of the Stranger," Clarke took control,
saying,
"I'm owning this, this is mine, they've asked
me to do it, and I am f---ing game."
Game of Thrones featured plenty of full-frontal
scenes during its decade-long run, and Clarke
performed her fair share.
From her wedding night with Khal Drogo to
her rebirth from the flames that gave way
to her dragons, some of those sequences actually
made sense within the plot of the show.
Beyond that, there were a handful of scenes
during which Clarke's Daenerys simply stripped
down for no narrative reason, which obviously
took its toll on the actress.
Thrones became infamous throughout its run
for using sex and nudity as narrative devices
even when it barely made sense to do so, and
clearly, the comments made to Clarke about
keeping her fans "happy" was no outlier.
Director Neil Marshall, who helmed the season
2 episode "Blackwater," once opened up about
how studio executives pushed him to add titillation
when it wasn't needed, proving that HBO brass
were likely more concerned with ratings than
how the Game of Thrones cast and crew felt
about the on-set environment.
In the end, it's great that Clarke found the
strength to stand up for herself and that
stars like Momoa stuck up for her when she
couldn't, but it's unsettling that the higher-ups
behind Game of Thrones pushed such a young
actress into performing scenes that made her
uncomfortable.
Ultimately, Clarke is clearly still proud
of the show that brought her international
fame, and how she handled this important on-set
dilemma will almost definitely help young
stars going forward.
If you miss Khaleesi, Game of Thrones is streaming
in its entirety on HBO Go and HBO On Demand.
If you want to catch Clarke in a new role,
her latest film, Last Christmas, is in theaters
now.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
actors are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.